hey everyone home welcome back to yet
another episode of watching The Watchmen
we are back again this is issue 9 you
know time is this a stick rubberband as
Manhattan teaches us and really the
series should have concluded by now it
should have concluded at the end of 2018
we are now closest to the middle of 2019
in the beginning of it but you know here
we are if you're familiar with the show
we've been going through well we started
off with the incredible work of you know
Alan Moore and Dave Gibbons and you know
Jay H as well Jay Higgs which was
amazing to have the colorist of the
watchman books on the show and we're in
murkier waters now we're going through
the I mean is kind of official Canon
sequel unfortunately we are talking
about Doomsday Clock we are pushing
through we are 75% of the way ish there
we're not really enjoying ourselves
there's been you know a little highs
here and there little moments that we've
enjoyed and some things that we've
disagreed and some things we've hated
some things we love whatever but we've
just got to get it done now
really and today we're tackling issue 9
which is called crisis is not just
myself is deaf hear deaf how's it going
how's it going tom I've got a question
for you who watches the Watchmen who
reads the what who read more Tom I mean
yeah it's I told you this one would be a
Bieber sea listeners Tom forgot will
record at about 20 minutes of the
episode but Tom he bloody forgot a
pressed record
so I going through it again well like
dr. Manhattan we live in lesson moments
in this podcast exactly I mean I'm glad
we did it now and not like you know I
discussed my show before I do a Bower
Bower podcast and when I had you know
jolly J's and look I realized half an
hour and I hadn't recorded anything and
I just didn't really know him and I just
recorded my own intro and edited in and
people didn't really seem to notice but
but yeah you know we did a little bit
but as we say these chronological
streams cross over and death what do you
remember of Doomsday Clock like to me if
you actually had to sit me down act upon
an a4 sheet of paper what's been going
on this story the big hitters
movers and shakers I find it quite
difficult yeah my brain sort of done a
reset almost because I feel like the
stories two parts
I couldn't sort of remember this stuff
in Russia that happened with firestorm
setting a bomb off but everything before
that is sort of a blur um and I think
it's purely because of just how much
stuff that there's going on like I've
been reading through civil war by marble
and which is about 110 issues long and I
do often catch myself sort of reading an
issue to issue and thinking like oh crap
this I must have zoned out in one of the
issues because I've just completely lost
what's happening and I think it's just
because there's so much going on and to
me the best graphic novels they are very
simplistic stories where the the story
sort of pushes the drama rather than the
drama pushing the story like if you
think of the the greatest graphic novels
of all time like from Hell which is
about Jack the Ripper sort of going
through London murdering prostitutes and
then getting beste Gaede very simple
story on the surface and the book kind
of deals with the complexities and the
psychology behind that The Dark Knight
Returns again it's about Batman sort of
returning to fight crime in Gotham in on
the way fights to face the mutant leader
the Joker and then Superman and it's
sort of this escalation up through
low-level crime all the way up to
Superman who you know stands as the
government himself very simple story
very easy to follow
whereas this it's just all over the
place
and because of that it's really
difficult to kind of remember all the
the the spinning plates and exactly
what's going on where I mean how many
characters are there in this there's
just so many here and they don't really
seem to have the the pacing down or you
know they're not releasing it at regular
intervals so it's becoming very for
straighting to kind of retread to your
memory and remember exactly what's going
on you know we're not dr. Manhattan Tom
what can't see all of this laid out in
front of us as a trade it might work
better but I kind of feel like the hype
is not there at the moment and it's just
yeah it's just feels like another story
that DC is doing and I feel like they've
dropped the ball quite a lot on this you
know dr. manhattan's one of the main
focal points in this issue but where the
[ __ ] of the rest of the Watchmen you
know that is marionette where's Reggie
where's [ __ ] the Mole Man where's
Nathan dusk like yeah honestly forgot
about the mime and marionette yeah just
there what they should have done is pick
a character who was gonna be our journey
through this world and stuck with them
Tom like who is the main character of
this book I honestly who is it and that
is a massive falling down narrative Lee
not many things work when they don't
have a main character one of the biggest
criticisms of Star Wars The Phantom
Menace is you don't know who the main
character is juxtaposing that Luke
Skywalker is the main character of the
original Star Wars trilogy I've got no
idea who the main character of the the
prequel trilogy is and you know books
really fall down and storytelling in
general it really if you don't have a
main character it's very hard to
continue a narrative and I know I'm
sounding off here like I'm some amazing
writer but it's it's a very simple thing
just have a pick and pick a character
and follow their journey they could have
picked Rorschach Ozymandias they could
have picked anyone from the DC Universe
but yeah I don't know who it is and
because of that it doesn't it doesn't
feel like there's a story and a weave
through the book it's just an event
after event from a different characters
perspective yeah yeah there's no sort of
protagonist progression I mean one
anomaly
you're completely right one anomaly that
my friend pointed out to me recently
that does work about a main character a
drastic park sitting even then though I
would say some Neil I guess so Alan yeah
I guess even you know you could all see
the t-rex another thing yeah how many
characters are there in Jurassic Park is
about six Tom this about 70 of them I
reckon this is why the issue took so
long to come out because we know Gary
Frank's a bit of a perfection is the
precision estándar heroes that he has
the drawer in certain sections must have
taken years yeah it's horrendous I feel
very sorry for the guy
it's what I [ __ ] on even the original
Watchmen Tom how many characters are in
that you can count them on one hand and
whilst yeah there's not really a main
character in the Watchmen
they all get their moment in the
spotlight they all get single focused
issues and you can sort of it works
better because it's building towards a
team piece like say a Avengers movie or
Justice League movie you know you've had
maybe not Justice League because they're
[ __ ]
but you know they've built up through
the years they've done single standalone
story so you can get used to the
characters and then they sort of put
them all together in one whereas this is
just putting them all together in one
and it's a [ __ ] let's talk about the
cover let's not spoil were writing yet
Oh Tom I know doc Manhattan in its
finest finest garb
right I mean you know yeah the the the
snappin eing all these characters
evaporating in their costumes is pretty
effective yeah but you brought it up
there it's you think of that ass before
you think of dr. Manhattan now dr.
Manhattan he's been in pop culture since
1985 and you know the the graphic novel
that he's in it's a it's regarded as the
best graphic novel of all time by many
many people and it just goes to show how
much DC have really dropped the ball
with the branding year
the hypetrain when you look at that and
my mind instantly just goes oh yeah it's
a bit like Dan Oster you know I mean Tom
the they've just been completely
overshadowed here rebirth was meant to
be a massive massive event in the DC
Universe that everyone was getting
behind like oh my god they're bringing
Watchmen in the DC Universe and I feel
like that hype is just completely died
down I don't see it anywhere you know it
might change when the the trade
paperback comes out but it just doesn't
feel like there was hype there even
before Watchmen had a lot more hype
behind it upon its release than I feel
like this does I mean this is building
up towards dr. Manhattan vs Superman and
where is the hype for that that's the
ultimate tagline yeah we are slowly
slowly crawling towards and you know
again there are so many references back
to Watchmen we open on the first page
with a nine panel grid with Manhattan on
the Red Planet you know harking back to
him living through multiple timelines
and experiencing it all at once that
singularity looking back to I think it's
watchmaker the fourth issue man-hands
origin issue which we both gushed wildly
and wildly about and you know it's not a
terrible sequencing the arts gray
I like the swap between the backdrop of
the stars at his head and his hand with
the ring and the crumbling earth beneath
but um you know we're getting into man
hands mine were getting this monologue
and we're not getting much else from it
really does Superman destroy me or do I
destroy everything again I'm not that
isn't Jon Osterman voice in my head talk
like that and you know why it is Tom and
I know at this town it's because he asks
himself a question if you read Watchmen
dr. Manhattan doesn't ask himself
himself a quest like questions because
he's so certain about everything
everything has a certainty to him so him
saying that does he let Superman destroy
him or does he destroy everything he
he's meant to be a puppet and he knows
that he is he's thoughts just straight
that he's given himself this question in
his choice because he should know the
answer and that's why it seemed so
different to me - to the root of the
character this is a guy who always has
the answer
um and it's just yeah not very good not
very accurate to me we've pointed out
many times that the titles of Doomsday
Clock have been quite clumsy but
especially in the DCU
the title crisis is such a loaded term
right yeah the massive massive term in
the DC universe it often refers to like
mega events such as crisis on Infinite
Earths infinity crisis and final crisis
nice it doesn't really feel deserving of
it to be honest it doesn't I don't see
what the crisis is here I know that
there was a bomb in Russia and
firestorms getting blamed and the heroes
are rushing across the galaxy it tracked
down this energy signature that set off
the bomb but like it doesn't really feel
like they're just investigating doesn't
feel like the crisis is they're going to
find out white is and then when they got
there that's when the crisis would start
yeah and the quote that it's deriving
from from Seneca the hugely influential
Greek dramatist and philosopher Seneca
probably most famous where Shakespeare
stole the five act structure from but
even the quote that it comes from which
we'll get to at the end an issue is a
really like pragmatic basic quote like
when I read that quote I was like duh I
think it's like something like every
shoot it every human presents an
opportunity for crisis or something it's
like well yeah of course they do I don't
know what's profound about that or deep
about that but that's kind of geoff
johns in a nutshell I will say that
these opening pages these tableaus of
characters most of whom I've got you
know I don't really know I mean these
are really [ __ ] cool I do actually I
don't you like these pages yeah so
you've got Hawkgirl court man Barda mr.
miracle the
Green on call arrow flash yes martian
manhunter my man it's a I wished it was
like an Alan Moore ship they kind of
hint towards with Constantine and Swamp
Thing but I would have been nice if they
threw a few more I know you didn't
really do much for thisi was more an
image and stuff like that
but but but yeah as as just a kind of
Easter egg hunt I do like these these
sequences yeah I like them but you know
what I'm conscious of tuck Tom time is
running out for this graphic novel and
they use three pages to just show people
traveling across space
what does pay dialog yeah there's no
exposition it just seems like a big
waste yeah anyway we'll discover they're
gonna Mars to trace the energy signature
from the firestorm explosion remember
that Tom remember the firestorm
explosion and with a glass at all that
Blauman of my life yeah yeah there's a
long pack their vagina alien yeah
there's a lot of looking back really and
the tachyons come in which are the
ultimate plot device which i think more
was kind of you know more kind of was
gleeful in the paradox of that and you
know a lot of watchman's tropes are kind
of aping these ideas whereas I think for
John's here it's just a sort of
necessity it's something that allows him
to tell his story you know we see the
Bruce is still breathing I mean Batman's
completely indestructible isn't he I
think he was in you know you know he's a
human he was in the eye of a bomb blast
but he's just he's slightly grizzled
yeah they can't kill him Tom he's their
biggest and the thing is that these
tachyons remind me of when you have like
a superman level character there always
is some convoluted way to depower them
like I don't know if you've seen Captain
Marvel yet Tom I have a they've got a
little neck thing that they put on ER
that deep powers there so you know it's
not a complete washout and when that
gets deactivated then she just goes wild
and nothing can really stand against her
the same isn't all Ragnarok they use a
little neck thingy there and the
tachyons to me are just like the little
plot device that they need to deep our
doctor man
and from just completely wiping everyone
out and yeah it's not good no no yeah it
was yeah it's already been in Watchmen
already yes yeah yes so yeah don't do it
again yeah exactly and there's just a
lot of lot of stuff you know sort of
heavy lifting here for the story telling
the metahumans idea is coming in and the
anti-superman sent a man and you know
the arts fantastic I think I think you
know Frank's is a great artist
absolutely no doubt he's clearly liked
it but if an artist an you know it
really takes his time for these things I
like the look of Lois hero's well ship
it modernized but um I mean did you feel
the same way like a lot of this I was
just mentally trying to play catch if I
was like I was like yeah we've spoken
about this book for probably like eight
hours the whole working day we've spoke
about Doomsday Clock but very little has
stuck at my memory whereas other things
that I've read once like you know I'm
currently reading I went to London the
other way - great comic book store
called gosh comics and had now more
section and one of the only things that
Alan Moore has done that's not been
released on paperback is 1963 which is
kind of his parody of Marvel Silver Age
comics like he does like the Fantastic
Four and then he does he does he does
his take on four but it's Egyptian gods
rather than Norse gods and it's really
[ __ ] cool and obviously it's more
with his brain but yes so much of this
is just sort of saved through my mental
brain yeah I know exactly what you mean
and again I think it goes back to the
how convoluted it is and how difficult
that information actually is to retain
it's very rare it's really honestly it's
rough I wish he just stuck with one main
character because it's difficult to kind
of keep up with exactly what's going on
I know I've been sucking dick Marvel's
dick yeah I've been sucking dick and
I've been sucking Marvel's dick but I
know this that episode especially I've
been circumaural stick but infinitely
wore this you could say well infinite he
was got 64 different characters in yeah
but it follows Danos as he interacts
with those characters and you know what
I mean it's still a main character in
that you follow through
where's this it's just so convoluted
there's so much information to retain I
don't even think the graphic novel knows
where it's going and didn't really feel
like it has a MacGuffin which these kind
of stories I feel is essential you need
sort of that thing where it's like it
did start out originally it was like we
need to find dr. Manhattan we've got to
go back and you end up in Manhattan and
then when they found him it I don't know
what the hell's happened from that on
there's not been that driving plot point
that's kind of pulling everyone together
there's not an infinity corner in here
Tom there's not Infinity stones that
someone's trying to collect there's not
a tesseract that someone and the
Avengers is trying to get you know I
mean or mother boxes they're massive
they're always a massive plot point in
DC crossover books and there's nothing
like that in this there's no MacGuffin
and because of that it's really
difficult to follow the threat the plot
threads because they're not sort of
driving towards this thing
yeah and introduced here I mean go and
we get the metahuman stuff we get
presidential tweets we learn Wonder
Woman is gonna go to the UN to address
this you know mass exodus of heroes
seems like every [ __ ] issue it's
Bruce Wayne recuperating and Albert
Alfred bringing him some ink and you
know he I just love that he wakes up and
asks where firestorm is ladies just
Soleil but I don't give a [ __ ] about
this guy and you know you know I find
funny Tom you know there's a bet that
says you can't wait to address this any
longer mr. president and that's
hilarious to me because as you know
Geoff Johns he sort of used to be the
president of DC right and he's taken
absolutely [ __ ] ages to address this
story Tom so he needs to take a leaf out
of his own book and is that a a little
Easter Egg if you look under the TV says
and 899 night you know is that like 89
when Watchmen came out is that maybe
yeah no that was a photon oh wow that's
embarrassing I got the wrong key I think
1285 yeah you know so let's just let's
not dwell on that let's move forward
and yet we have Bruce in the manor bruce
healey not bruce asking about firestorm
more fire storms
whoo he's like two guys in one Roy I
can't again yeah yeah very jarring even
for me who knows a lot about the
character this is the first time we've
actually seen them separated yes in the
graphic novel and so it took me like a
couple of well not a couple of pages but
you know it took a while that kind of
reading I click on go I'll [ __ ] that's
firestorm of course but just badly
introduced really really badly and I
would challenge anyone the first time
they're reading this to get to that
panel where they're talking and go
alright that's fire swamps straight away
it's just yeah it's not no well don't ya
ya know completely agree it's quite nice
reveal when the roof pulls back and
they're in space and stuff like that I
mean it's quite typical really we get
lots of information as John's likes to
do from television you know we learn
through green arrow as well about the
divisions that are occurring and just
just just not lots of talking lots of
kind of uninteresting action being
played out we see Rorschach's mask
Reggie's mask against the journal as
well oh yeah everybody locked him in the
asylum and watch yeah just so long ago
probably like a year and half go you
know genuinely yeah did this come out
when did it start I think it came out
like 2011 teen like I think that was
round about when he came out yeah yeah
it was I mean oh yeah I've moved house
in that time I remember us doing the
episode in my old house like so it's
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] crazy let's move
forward you know Bruce pondering Mars
heading off to Mars and that sort of
stuff we get quite a lot Green Lantern
cool stuff as well early on them for
standing on the planet yeah which you
get in there just bringing these
characters in Tom and I do like the
Green Lantern Corps but are they the
right is this the right time to bring
them into the story you know I mean a
big problem that I have with this issue
and the arc in general is that it kind
of pressed the reset button in issue 8
and kind of start again and I feel like
this should be issued to when I was
reading that I was like right this
feels like it's setting up some stuff
and this should be like an interesting
issue too but no its issue 9 Tom and I
don't know what the hell they're going
with it no no you know we have the
checkerboard which have we seen that
before
I imagine in that wasn't that like it's
yeah Mayberry was I think when they met
dr. Manhattan it was on a giant and then
transported away and you must have took
that with them yeah and then we get the
the photo of Jon Osterman and Janey
which again go back to our watchmen
episodes where we love the source
material and we Waxler Acorah members
talk about the photo for quite a while
and I think I was like dwelling on like
all the balloon flying off and the
frayed edges and all that sort of stuff
but there's no real nuance or nouse here
it's some wisecracking Green Lanterns
and lots of heroes and and and voices
chatting and then kind of descending on
and it is quite cool to see the
Manhattan structure at the bottom of
page 14 they're like you know I'm not
gonna say it doesn't excite me seeing
these things in the comic but then I
suddenly realized where I am and get a
bit disillusioned yeah and you know what
another thing that I've just realized is
Tom they've got lots of heroes but they
don't have a villain in this graphic
novel there's not a villain like you
don't even have like the the mask killer
that you had from Watchmen mm-hmm
there's not like it just feels so
unbalanced and there's not um there's
not a main hero there's not villain it's
just doing [ __ ] that's happening so who
cares who does care yes clear that
Superman's being denounced as an
American hero in the graphic novel which
I kind of get their building awards this
met the world hates met humans thing
because the Justice League Oh in hiding
um but Superman was never like a massive
American hero anyway like well the last
couple of decades he hasn't been he was
before that obviously but a big story in
the comics once was that he decided to
become an ambassador for the world
and not just America hmm and since then
to me at least he's always being kind of
this hero of the world whereas now it's
like he's America and he stands for all
that wears I don't know it's a bit of an
outdated ideology for me but I guess
people are coming into the comics now
might be like yeah he stands for America
I can't believe America I hate Superman
I'll be what people are saying is they
walk down the streets of New York and
then someone else will shoulder button
and go hey I'm walking here
that's her imagine New York be like yeah
I know I think I think that's a spot-on
depiction really yeah if you're from New
York right in unless you know if we
listen to your glisters out there I'm
sure possibly we do and I'd like to
think that they are as disappointed as
we are with this debacle um they're not
Tom I've been reading the reviews yo the
reviews are clearly bought they wrote
they cannot be true they cannot be true
just in their shells right my skills I
think IGN are definitely shells I mean
it's not it's the whole the whole
gamergate thing isn't it it's like
they've kind of got to be in the pockets
of them to be giving yeah memos and
whatever and it's kind of a hard truth
and yeah it's just it I just you you
read that sort of stuff and it just it
just baffles the mind really but but
then you know that happens a lot like
romo winning Best Foreign Film over
shoplifters was just ridiculous in my
eyes ah but yeah that that's for a
different day so yeah the lanterns are
here they're defending the planet by
covering it in like a green shield I
think and like foil shield is haunted by
the professor and it's like I was like
well what's going on what is happening
and that's another problem with this
it's not accessible either so yeah bear
Tony what told me you better have 20
Batman posters on your wall and have 700
DC graphic novels to understand all this
because it's all over the place you
there's so much back reading that you
have to do to understand this graphic
novel that you know some people might
love it might be
hard core DC fans wet dream but I'm
pretty much a hardcore DC fan I tell you
what Tom not an enjoyable story for me
it's not so [ __ ] it it's not it has it
has very little momentum and and pace
honestly it just felt like we're just
thrown into all these different areas
you know what it is I think it's big
right
newcomers not gonna understand what's
going on and a hardcore DC fan like
myself we were getting disappointed
because we're expecting more and kind of
we've seen it all done before but better
so it's disappointing two groups of
people come it is it is I don't really
don't know who it's who it's pleasing to
be honest with you it is just you know
an absolute legend yeah yeah yeah it's
pleasing [ __ ] yet fandom and AAA cool
news and you know whatever those are but
but but yeah no it's not not not
pleasing us and um you know the descent
of the heroes on to Manhattan's palace
is pretty cool I suppose the
interactions aren't really they're a
little bit of a letdown like I don't
really know who this guy is in the Green
Lantern cause it's like a bit of a sort
of New Jersey tough guy
he kind of leads the way for a lot of
this we have harks back to when they're
out there on Karnak and dr. Manhattan is
talking through time and they're
protesting a power they fear he says and
then he reveals into someone else
six minutes in the future we get into
well before we get into the fisticuffs
like it's quite cool that the sort of
lanterns are like you know we've battled
these people before let us show you
these people we've battled before and I
don't really know the point of this like
again it feels a little bit treading
water like the earlier sequences just
cool stuff to drawers no really yeah and
stuff that fans have gone well like in
stays there and yeah March Agron and
yeah yes Lord Sinestro we say to you
let's see number Sinestro Tom they're
just great yeah but yet completely [ __ ]
just this entire thing like I don't want
to keep hogging him back to civil war
because of sell at thousand times
but this it just feels to me like civil
war but not as developed you're like
from reading that I can see that the
entire run of that completely outweighs
this and obviously they've got a hundred
and ten issues but I didn't actually
like the main arc of civil war that much
of my first read but once you read it
with all the side stories I think it's a
masterpiece and this just feels so dull
in comparison it doesn't even feel like
a watchman story it's just so far
removed and whilst in Watchmen you know
superheroes would announced and the
Keene act yeah I believe yet it just
feels like here this whole metahuman act
it's not as interesting and that's
because the main plot point be that's
because it's becoming the main plot
point where is in The Watchmen it was
sort of a backdrop to the plot and not
the big driving force and I can see what
John's is trying to do like in Watchmen
Ozymandias steps in to stop the world
from destroying itself in a war between
Russia and America and we do get that
tension here but it just doesn't feel as
well-developed
because it's being introduced in issue 9
instead of issue 1 where it should be
yeah and it's just it's crap it's too
trying to jam it all in at the end and
hoping that everything sort of falls in
place yeah whereas it's not it's not
good it is mad isn't it it's like the
first proper confrontation with okay
he's not the villain but but he's kind
of the antagonist dr. Mann and to a
certain extent easily of characters we
have no clue like characters yes spent
no time move and Doomsday Clock is a
book for all its flaws that does take
time with its characters and lets you
know their motivations to some extent
and gives you flashbacks and you know
remember the marionette flashback as
well with mime and you know and what we
said was so true by the way the cops
that investigated them should have been
the cops the investigated comedians
murder like why did it like please
revise that and do that like they
definitely should know so yeah this guy
this slug this [ __ ] [ __ ] this
ginger punch he stopped behind in the
face thinks that he's killed him
obviously he's not
dead he comes back it's quite cool the
Manhattan takes the ring and isn't
certain what its gonna be and that leads
to some mystery for him yeah I didn't
mind that part I thought that was a nice
kind of interaction of the worlds yeah
it's alright now
yeah that's guy garden up by the way not
ginger [ __ ] right right okay he's
healer he's a big deal right yes so like
in the nineties he was he's there was
one sort of DC were so changing of all
the characters a bit and Guy Gardner I
think it was the night he stayed became
the new Greenland the new kid on the
block
I remember reading like comic books from
back then a clip so I remember reading
that and there was like actually think I
remember the slogan now Tom he's
standing there with his ring and it goes
there's a new guy in town I think that
was the slogan Guy Gardner comics and
obviously you read that you go tell you
what I want to hug and pick this up yeah
well you know he comes in with his Blue
Man Group joke I mean which is funny
except for it's been done 900 times
before in this bit dick there as well
Tom there is there is he won't be a blue
dick he's a blue dick before yeah so
Manhattan has that stuck with all these
gay jokes actually Tom you know
everyone's welcome in this podcast it's
inclusive I've seen Captain Marvel twice
so there's you bigoted even like it I
think it was in the original Watchmen
room we said so it really offensive I
can't even remember I think we had to
edit it out it was something like really
like probably didn't I shall have to go
back and listen you didn't like Captain
Marvel did you say we're gonna get
canceled well yeah I thought was alright
the wife looked at though yeah you know
do you ever got the cinema with like
your girlfriend and you sit there and
you're watching it and you think oh my
god she hates this and we've got two
hours and I now can't enjoy it because
I'm sitting yes stressing out that she
just like it I had that the entire time
thinking [ __ ] oh this is so bad and
she turned to me at the end she was like
'hey that's one of the best superhero
movies I've ever seen well
that I don't they were watching the same
thing but fair enough you know I'm not
gonna take it away from you you're a
female it's a female superhero it's for
you enjoy it this was fine Tom it was
fine
I say it was really bad it was fine yeah
I mean look I'm never gonna I just know
how functional these films can be so
yeah it's not really something that
appeals to me
I did see spider-verse recently though
that is [ __ ] fire like that really
it's strange that Sony managed to make
that and venom in the same year yeah I
understand what goes on there Tom I
think they'd probably sit down for like
three days of work a week and they'd be
either two days that just [ __ ] about in
the probably wrote spider-verse in those
three days and Benham in the other two
we psycho I think it's Phil Miller or
Chris Lord it was one of them too who
was writing it and they're you know
they're [ __ ] geniuses they are they
auntie Geoff yawns and and speaking of
female supers we get this some magician
woman that we get this magician woman
who has possibly one of my highlights of
doing thing like the whole Donna what
does she say here as if that's when she
casts a spell
she um casts spells by saying things
backwards so yeah and you can have a lot
of fun with that Tom yeah in writing
only because there was an animated DC
movie um where she was one of the
characters and I think she just said the
spell forward but when when it's in
writing the right of backwards and it
look it's really fun it's a fun it's a
fun thing to read Tom because you know
you read it and you're trying to figure
out what you're saying yeah but yeah
it's not a love I love her I love a bit
cetana but if she does I don't think
they're bringing it to the big screen
warner brothers are but i don't know how
they're gonna do that the backwards
spell thing so Manhattan is came in
peace and you know they just realized
time I made a note of this those people
that pop up that guy Gordon the shows
from
the ring like dooms their head so
Darkseid
oh yeah doomsday is that handy monitor
they're all villains from other crisis's
scissors okay okay interesting
that's why I shown them so other DC
crisis is scissors they're the villains
okay that's yeah that's just that noise
that's nice and I mean there are here is
still really [ __ ] good actually and I
think I specially like the explosions I
think Frankie's does not very very well
of course the heroes stand no chance
against Manhattan and then just as the
plots getting good we get some turgid
scenes between Lex and Lois you know
making deals at the eleventh hour as
they always like they just reminded me
of that incredible all-star Superman
story where where Clark goes to
interview Lex during a prison break yeah
I did yeah just yeah we said before how
much we idolize those comics and though
they are astonishingly good but yeah
this sequence again kind of enigmatic
not really clear what's going on here
cliche very cliche very cliche it's the
old give someone a weapon you know so
they can kill you but they actually
trust you and then they're seen this
panel memed everywhere on Instagram Lex
brings up Wally West who was removed
from the DC Universe in the new 52 and
then he was the one who returned to
kickstart rebirth it's a big thing
apparently online put on a theory that
didn't really give a [ __ ] okay that's
interesting there do you give a [ __ ] no
I don't really it's not really clear
like I'm you know the only thing that I
know about the flash is that there's
that clip of the TV show that has that
giant shark guy in it that looks [ __ ]
awful I couldn't believe it was on like
network TV
I thought the shot we're really good Tom
one I don't think I've seen King shock
for a while but I remember at the time
being a whoa God believe this is on TV
yeah you know I had the same reaction as
you but a different tone of voice and
then yeah the fighting goes down
we're learning about you know wonder
woman going to the UN and more firestorm
stuff as well and doctor I mean doc you
know like we've had on Mars before we've
with Laurie where dr. Manhattan was
showing her her past and out fraction it
was and comedians your father and all
this sort of stuff well here we have
this but does such a smaller degree like
yeah terrible yeah no you that wouldn't
a woman UN ambassador
by the way that thing in real life
Wonder Woman was the UN ambassador for
women's rights I think I think it would
anyway when the movie come out they made
her like a UN ambassador for women's
rights oh I think that's just a little
nod to that right that's right yeah I
did yeah which was a stupid idea yeah I
mean it might be sexist I don't get I
didn't get what the point was surely
made gal gadot an ambassador don't make
fictional character Wonder Woman yeah in
India but yet it gets attacked by
Giganta and black Adam that's Rorschach
and but I do think the dr. Manhattan
fights quite interesting when he pieces
themselves back together yeah yeah you
see the nervous system but mmm-hmm and
that's kind of it right I mean you know
we push forward and and like yet like
you say she's in the UN and they all
come through and it's still cool to see
Manhattan in his exoskeleton kind of
form there I think that that's so bad
like if there was like because I have
that DC fighting game don't they like
yeah that'd be cool alternate costume
for the doctor man hand character yeah
definitely definitely
I'm surprised they haven't put them in
the game oh you actually get him in yeah
but we also see that Osmond ice is kind
of pulling the strings a bit here unless
this is a twist when he presses the
enter key mm-hmm and it's meant it being
like red herring showing that cause
human dice is behind the whole thing but
maybe he's not I don't know
okay no
that's the crucial thing yeah I've got
no interest in that we get to the quote
by Seneca which again I think mayor I
think that's a such a lame quo and and
John's just has a tin ear for quotation
I really don't like where goes that
whereas you know just worked multiple
Manhattan like levels with his ideas
with his quotes here the characters are
smoking I know you don't really look
into the back matter I mean this is
actually the leanest section yet it's
basically a single case file
dr. mines Stein's plans and motivations
for what will become the firestorm
project I mean you know it lends some
credence and veracity to the claims that
some meta beings were being created blah
blah blah but again the whole metahuman
meta being idea it's just a bit of a
lame duck narrative Lee for me yeah it's
I don't care it's not really getting
that mention it doesn't seem that
important in the story so why should I
care yeah you know so not really yeah
it's not a big point for me so don't
care Tom okay come get it over with
I've got people I've got too many
subscribers now ever be yeah messing
around with it's not even get views it's
not like we do it and there are people
love it it's like no it's kind of no I'm
really good so let's have a look on the
website at Matt Analytics yeah
doomsday okay number oh no it's
Nathanael dusk on the cover number ten
is on April April 24th so that's a lie
cuz held that yeah no you're right it
will it will but I mean you know
potentially that's when we'll be back
but yeah we dear listeners me and they
despise this series quite clearly and I
think we've pointed out quite succinctly
whites floors are and this wasn't even
fun just to readers just a bit of
[ __ ] comic book to read you know
anime it's not even bad it's not
terrible enough it's not like a holy
terror by Frank Miller which is
definitely read that if you want a
absolutely [ __ ] graphic
that's really hilarious to read yeah but
yeah she read out some other people's
reviews Tom yeah and then read some
comics I hope you don't have any where I
go let's go I've cancelled all my plans
for tonight
it looks like IGN haven't actually
reviewed issue 9 it's gonna because oh
wait they've give it an 8 so yeah yeah
have they reviewed issued 9 cuz it just
looks like oh wait half yeah yeah I
found it I found it so what's the
perfect got great hey-oh 10 Doomsday
Clock settles at least one nerdy debate
as we see what happens when dr.
Manhattan goes to war against a very
angry Justice League that confrontation
brings a welcome sense of fun to an
otherwise bleak book though the darkness
still carries the day this issue is also
notable for advancing the Superman
theory subplot and establishing it as
more than just convenient plot device
how that's bad they've not even checked
that Tom yeah you know part very bad
grammar
however the continued absence of so many
Watchmen characters is becoming a
problem for the series and that in their
eyes give get an A so I have a 10 per
meet that that to me if I read that
verdict there was like room I wonder
what school I'm sure they did this last
time as well where they the verdict was
really bad and they gave it like in 9
out of 10 I just don't think i GN
couldn't give bad reviews you know Tom I
really don't think they got too much
money
peddling this [ __ ] they know what
happened comic book roundup it's got a
9.2 user rating and a critic rating of
8.6 10/10 scores
yeah I'm just looking now there are
loads of tens and they pretty much evens
out at about the 7th members there's
only one free from Matthew pious and
this issue for so should the get
beginning of the end the combination
what the series been getting ass is
beginning but it's still unclear what's
going on whether this book is relevant
any longer yeah Matt you're a small
yeah well let's read one of the let's
bounce it out with a really big score
perfect ten comics The Gathering I have
to say that this is probably one of the
best issues so far you know I'm doing it
in that accent I just want a job at IGN
Tom that's why I really want right it
gives the readers what they wanted in
terms of there being a bite between dr.
Manhattan and the DC Universe but it
also propels the many Superman theory
fault story forward as well
Gary Frank's art is phenomenal in his
issue and I do think that it makes it
well worth the wait yeah he's also good
in it oh yeah 10 or 10 for that so we've
got some more a tell some comments as
well do we we do do do us till afternoon
the voice already if you want to only if
you wanted Oh Aaron Ferguson area good
intro not cunning laughing my ass off oh
yeah I think I remember uh saying that
yeah yeah Erik punt thank you for this
review you are right too many characters
it's a mess one question you said you
switched to Marvel what is your opinion
on Dark Knight's metal I see some
resemblance with Doomsday Clock too many
storylines actually like Dark Knight
smell and basically in that graphic
novel there's a dark multiverse it turns
out but in that dog multiverse all the
Batmen of it have went mental
and they've killed all the other heroes
so you've got a green lanten Batman
you've got a Aquaman well I like a woman
Batman like a Superman Batman a cyborg
Batman and I think it's really really
good a really creative and they kind of
come to the forefront you might have
seen the joke a he's called the Batman
who laughs and he sort of like a joker
with like like night outfit on but if
it's difficult that basically it's sort
of like loads of leather it's metal Tom
it's metal as [ __ ] it looks like a
Metallica cover
love that okay and yet Scott Snyder's
involved in it right yeah so Google
Batman the man who laughs um no sorry
the Batman who laughs and that's sort of
the main villain of it cuz as well as
like the bat guard Bob battles and I
really like it and I did read a lot of
the graham Morrison's stuff that set
that up so I dunno kind of the ins and
outs of it but I really liked it but
apparently people don't okay Josh whoa
cool root Josh whoa cool sorry two
months ago I still like this series but
it's quite honestly frustrating why
would one in a DC / watchman crossover
story are the washerman characters
interacting with Superman / Batman some
of the chunk comic characters and maybe
the JSA yeah I think that is a big
problem of the graphic novel that the
characters aren't really interacting
with one another like team-up comics
they often start off the two characters
meet each other and they're bit unsure
of each other and have a fight and then
the team up to take down the main
villain whereas this they've met hope to
have a fight do you Muppet take the main
villain and this blurb and then I don't
know what the hell's going on anymore
and cyan blue it has become a horrible
story can't wait for you to [ __ ] on this
issue like you did the last one thank
you for that same blue I remember guys
if you if there's only four of you is
coming in on every episode then all the
comments get read out yeah so make sure
you come in again and yeah email us as
well we didn't have any emails this week
but next time we'll get into those are
watching The Watchmen part at Gmail calm
let us know what you think about
Doomsday Clock or you know anything else
really in the comment yeah I will no
really hear someone say why they like it
and kind of debate our points yeah like
do you like that the story doesn't have
a main character do you like that the
story doesn't have a villain do you like
that it's like that it ruins the legacy
of Watchmen like yeah do you like
because there will be like there's
people giving it tends out the board and
I really want someone here we need to
find someone you know I'm gonna start
emailing at people are IGN and being
like do you want to come on the show and
defend it
you be there will be great yeah so
anyone in the comments just write what
you like about it just do a bullet point
list don't need a write an essay but I
want 5,000 words on my desk by Monday
and this Dan you better [ __ ]
subscribe yeah subscribe to the Deaf's
channel not they really needs it
subscribe to my channel I definitely
need it if you like alphabet a like if
you like Metallica sorry the show is
called an alpha tiger or battle rap
check out all the deaths explain stuff
as well don't bother going to the movies
anymore guys the movies are so last year
just watch that and then explain on
YouTube
and we will be back we'll try to be a
bit more time if at saddle ends episode
slightly but you know I think you guys
can forgive us for that because it isn't
the most done and Ellie got delayed
again it did it did it Nelly also didn't
get recorded if he did it such rigmarole
but we did get there in the end and we
will be back towards the end of April to
tackle issue 10 I don't really want to
say that we do but we do we're almost
there so we might as well push on to the
end I mean death Andy penny Final Fours
anything like that no tips like it
comment it subscribe it alright well uh
yeah this has been Tom keep reading
graphic novels go back and read Watchmen
you know scrub the taste of this from
your brain and enjoy some fantastic work
every month for this episode just go
back and read watch yeah yeah go back
and listen to all Watchmen stuff as well
still very very proud of that I think we
we get some great analysis there but
deaf until next month man this has been
great it's a good night from me
it's a good night from Queen
[Music]